GOOD MORNING RULES COMMITTEE
FOR THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY NINETEEN IS HEREBY
CALLED PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
AUDIO AND VIDEO REPORTED TODAY
FOR SEASON IS BEING MADE AS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED -- OUT
OF SACRIFICE CALL THE ROLL
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HERE
LARA GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RIVAS WICKS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOST OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA SEC BOOMERS COME ORDER
SIGNED BY MR MATHESON -- MATTER
SECTOR PIECE CULTURAL COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA
I'VE RUN MOST RIVAS RIVERSIDE
WICKS MOTION PASSES THE MOTION
IS PASSED THE SCHOOLS PLACE
TO TURN THANK YOU VERY MUCH